Bachelorette star Chad Johnson is making
it clear he misses us just as much as we
miss him and his chat isms Here I am
Monday was our first episode of Jo Jo
season without Chad and it was boring
but the 28 year old real estate agent
hopped on Twitter during the show and
did not disappoint he shared a bunch of
hilarious comments starting with this
Nicolas Cage meme with miss me yet
written on it the answer is yes Chad
though he may not have found love with
Jojo the reality star seems to be
looking on the bright side writing no
matter what happens in life at least I
can always wake up and be like well at
least I'm jacked yep you can bad Chad
also shared his take on the show's
ratings since his departure he tweeted
when Jojo sent me home and everyone
changed the channel lol along with this
gift congratulations you played yourself
The Bachelorette villain also came up
with a brilliant idea they should invite
me back and I'll just stand next to
Chris Harrison and provide commentary on
everything hashtag the Bachelorette
hashtag chat isms we definitely agree
come back Chad